this is the kurta which is the only
mechanical pocket digital calculator
ever invented it was invented by Kurt
Hutt stuck who's an Austrian engineer
who had the idea in the 1930s because
for the previous 300 years there's been
this this desire by people to mechanize
calculating because calculators quite
effortful quite difficult when we great
machines could do it for us and the
first person to have this idea was
pascal at 1650 who invented the
Pascaline and then liveness invented his
step reckoner and Citrix etc by the
Victorian age there were these big desk
calculators where you know that's where
the phrase number-crunching comes from
people would do these complicated
multiplications not complicate just long
multiplications using machines but there
was always the dream to try and make it
a bit more user-friendly to make a
pocket-sized one but the challenge was
to get the right kind of engineering and
cut hurt stock in the 1930s thought he'd
found a way but it took him another 20
years to develop it and one of the
problems was that the Second World War
happened he was half Jewish living in
Austria so he was imprisoned in the
concentration camp but because he was
quite a well-known engineer the Nazis
said we won't kill you we'll let you
develop your pocket calcaneal calculator
which he did they didn't kill him and
I'm not sure if he hadn't got there yet
or if he had got there but didn't want
to tell his Nazi captors because very
shortly after war when he was liberated
he worked out how to do it and he tried
to you know gain get some investment
it's quite difficult getting investment
for was essentially an executive toy and
it was only in Liechtenstein and the
Duchy of Liechtenstein day that the
royal family they're invested in him and
in the 1960s 50s and 60s about a hundred
thousand of these Curtiz were made and
they were very kind of then are collects
items I'm going to show you exactly how
they work you put the number down here
your input number so what I put there
for there 68 and when you turn
around it will add whatever number is
here on the sides to here where the
output number comes so I put it to 68
I'm going to turn this around and you
can see it goes to 68 there if I turn it
around again it adds another 68 and
another 68 and another 68 we can keep on
going and now I've done it five times so
five times 68 is 340 because you might
forget how many times you've been
turning around there's a market here
five which reminds me that I've done it
right put it around five times so goes
on to six seven so seven times 68 is 476
you can do a whole lot more than that
let's multiply by a two-digit number so
well firstly let's zero it which is
quite good fun zeroing it you just pull
it up and turn that around it's now
completely zero that's let the Clear
button on calculator exactly is the C
then you put this but these ones at the
top so let's say we want to do say 24
times 33
let's put 24 here two and then four so
33 33 we need to multiply three times
one two three and then the clever thing
now is that we move it from units to
tens and we do another three times one
two three so we have multiplied that 33
times three units three on the tens and
the answer is 792 it's a beaut it's
beautiful machine I mean this is older
than me it's you know 50 years old it
looks brand-new
it's sturdy and tough and what was
cutting about it is that in the 60s it
was toy essentially
of rally drivers and their co-pilots
because often when you're a driving that
also calculations need to do about
speeds fuels distances but if you had a
slide rule you'd be slipping all over
the place or as with this you could do
this into the proper calculations you
know exactly and you're never going to
slip and it's just it's like an
absolutely beautiful thing it was of the
zenith of the dream of mechanizing
calculation it was sort of the end of
the road it was sort of the most perfect
and beautiful mechanized calculator and
then what happened a few years later you
know overtaken by electronic calculation
and calculators so this was as far as it
got along the road of mechanized
calculation I bought this on eBay you
can get them for about 500 quid although
hopefully now it cost a little bit more
so it's also an investment let's say we
want to do I'll just pull this numbers
what's this this is three million two
hundred forty two thousand three hundred
and thirty three and just say I want to
multiply this by six hundred and seventy
eight I will go eight oh five six seven
eight one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six so six
hundred and seventy eight times three
million two hundred and forty two
thousand three hundred and thirty three
is
two billion 198 million three hundred
and one thousand seven hundred and
seventy four last one
what were those little silver things you
moved around then at the end well these
things here at just where you would put
the commas just to remind me like
literally like the comments that that's
that's all it is every number files
favorite tie